it's fairly easy to determine that the
Western world was elated when the USSR
collapsed but what was the reaction of
the rest of the Communist world
how did nations like China Vietnam and
Cuba feel about the leading communist
state falling apart so perhaps the
ussr's closest ally was Cuba and Fidel
Castro had a few choice words for a
start he felt that it was completely
avoidable and blamed Gorbachev for
reforming everything too quickly Castro
was critical from an ideological
perspective but he had much more
practical reasons to be upset
so as of the American trade embargo Cuba
relied on the USSR for the majority of
its trade and it's hard to trade with
the defunct State has demonstrated by
the fact that Cuban exports to the
post-soviet States decreased by 93
percent of what it had been three years
earlier this led to a near collapse of
the Cuban economy so things were pretty
bad as such Cuba turned to the Western
world and found willing markets except
one for its goods
Cuba's other concern was security since
the USSR was its guarantor and there
were concerns about what the United
States was going to do turns out it was
nothing but for Cuba the years after the
collapse of the USSR were extremely
difficult so what about China the second
most prominent communist state and one
which had a pretty rocky relationship
with the Soviet Union well first of all
Jiang Zemin the leader of the Chinese
Communist Party came to a different
conclusion to Castro he believed that
the USSR had collapsed because the
reforms hadn't gone far enough and that
the wrong people had been asked to
implement them so how did the collapse
affect China's policies well internally
there was basically zero changed since
China was dealing with its own issues in
its leadership was keen to push ahead
with economic reforms in terms of
foreign policy the Chinese government
believed that the West was now going to
focus on fomenting internal revolution
there and that they would use the newly
non communist Russia as well as Taiwan
to help with this now the fear of some
reverse domino effect wasn't without
merit since only a year later Mongolia
would also see the end of communist rule
so what about Vietnam the leadership
there was obviously shocked by the
decline and collapse of Soviet Communism
but the trauma was mostly ideological
Vietnam was primarily concerned with the
economic ramifications of the USSR's
collapse and so sought to improve
relations with China said that they
could both be better protected in terms
of immediate fears the Vietnamese
leadership had little concerns as they
believed that the collapse of the USSR
was down to wet Nick tensions something
that they didn't have to deal with and
as for North Korea well Kim il-sung and
the North Korean leadership were
certainly worried
themselves facing the same fate as East
Germany and being incorporated into the
neighboring Democratic state however for
the past 20 years they've been weaning
themselves off her Soviet support and
said the collapse wasn't too damaging in
fact the only immediate problems were
that the new Russian Federation called
for talks between the north and the
south and that reunification should be a
potential end goal now the rest of the
Communist world was fairly quiet about
it and this was because they leave a
seen the writing on the wall because it
didn't affect them too much
Yugoslavian politicians for example
place the blame on the Russian ethnic
majority since they felt that it was the
duty of the country's largest ethnic
group to keep things together in the
face of any threats a theory that they
themselves would put to the test not
long afterwards I hope you enjoyed this
episode and a special thanks to all my
patreon supporters James vis annette
marvin castle a man of culture kelly
moneymaker danny Meloni Jon bisko's Rob
Waterhouse Moe Aaron the white James
Castaneda Gustav Swan Jordan long ray
Marcus Ozma spinning three plates
cooling Castleman filled oink oink
Rashid Ali David Silverman easy Maggie
packs Kowski Spencer Lightfoot Winston
Cawood Robert Wetzel Lexi Schwinn
Anthony Beckett and Skye Chappell
everybody was worried about the nukes
though